hoy el presidente Lula bromeado con el
canciller Olaf shows recordando aquella
Trágica derrota de Brasil contra
Alemania el famoso 7-1 en los mundiales
de 2014 antes de abordar los temas
importantes del día sin duda el
principal es el acuerdo comercial entre
el mercosur y la Unión Europea que había
quedado congelado durante el gobierno de
Jair bolsonaro Lula anunciado que ya en
julio de este año se podría alcanzar el
tan esperado acuerdo comercial también
se ha hablado y mucho de medio ambiente
porque Alemania es uno de los países
europeos que más dinero aporta al fondo
amazonía que había quedado también de
nuevo suspendido al principio del
gobierno de bolsonaro debido a las dudas
que tenían los gobernantes europeos
sobre las reales intenciones de
bolsonaro de preservar la amazonía y
evitar la deforestación sabemos que
Alemania podría aportar hasta 200
millones de euros no sólo amazonia pero
también para realizar otro tipo de
acciones medioambientales en Brasil y
finalmente también se ha abordado el
espinoso asunto de la guerra entre Rusia
y Ucrania Lula ha dicho que Rusia es sin
duda culpable de la invasión del
territorio Pro ha recordado que dos no
pelean si uno no quiere una forma de
responsabilizar al gobierno ucraniano de
la situación actual y ha propuesto crear
un grupo de países para intentar mediar
un acuerdo de paz